what do you think of Melanie who's more
afraid of commitment men or women I
think men I think he's correct in terms
of who you want to talk about marriage
but if you want to talk about I think
it's twofold I think if we're talking
about marriage it's going to be men just
because of the consequences that if it
doesn't work out and the responsibility
what it means to a man men have very
little benefits to being married uh
women have most of the benefits to being
married but I will say this in terms of
just like commitment relationships women
have more options in terms of swiping
right and they always the hypergamy and
and they they always want something
better something something better can
come along there why would I do I want
to settle with him because uh oh who
just popped in my DM